Florian from neuro nine has a popular software
YouTube channel. And in this course he will
teach you how to use the VIM code editor. What is
going on guys? Welcome to this vim course on Free
Code Camp. In today's video, I want to guide you
through a full vim course from beginning to end
step by step. And I want to start out with some
basic motivation, talking about why to use Vim,
what vim actually is, and also showing you a
preview of what vim can look like if you have some
plugins installed and all that. And I want to do
so because I think for a lot of people out there,
VIM is this boring feature list text editor that
you have. In the Linux command line. If you don't
have any alternatives on a server, for example,
you use Vim, otherwise, you don't use Vim,
and a lot of people don't even know how to exit
Vim and all that. So we're going to talk about all
this why you should use Vim, why learning vim can
be important and interesting. And then we're going
to move on to the installation to finding the
installation that you already have to installing
vim on Windows. For example, if you don't have
it installed natively, we're going to talk about
that. And then we're going to get into some basic
key bindings commands into more intermediate key
bindings commands to more advanced key bindings,
commands and so on. Then we're going to talk about
macros and registers. And in the end, we're going
to wrap up with plugins and neovim. So we're going
to talk about how to build an actual sort of
IDE or at least an advanced editor something
approximating VS code, or even better using
plugins and Neo Vim. So let us get right into it.
Alright, so let us get started with the
motivational part where I'm going to show you
or explain to you why using vim can be interesting
to you. And I'm not going to talk too much here,
I'm just going to show you my setup and what I can
do with it. And then you can decide if you think
that's interesting or not. But before we get into
that, I want to mention that this box down here
is showing you what keys I pressed. So right now
I'm in the terminal, and I can type ABC, and you
can see that I'm typing ABC up here. But you can
also see what I'm typing down here. And you can
also see that if I press backspace, for example,
this is also locked here. And if I press Enter,
it is also locked. So whatever I press, whatever
I type, you can see down here on the right,
this is important because a lot of times when
I do something in Vim, you're going to see
certain effects, but you don't really see what I'm
pressing. So here on the right, you can see what
kind of keys I'm pressing in order to do certain
things. And I want to show you first of all, would
probably most of you know VIM is or no vim looks
like or think about when they think about Vim,
and this is essentially just a VI command. So VI
and opening a file, I have prepared a C file here
clients dot c. And when I opened this, this is
what probably most of you know s Vim, just a basic
text editor here, you don't even know how to leave
it, probably, you don't know what to do with it,
you don't know how to type with it, maybe you
know how to type in how to leave. But that's
it. This is not what I'm using on a daily basis.
When I talk about using vim on a daily basis,
what I'm using is new vim with a couple
of plugins. And with my custom settings,
indented can look like that. So in vim clients see
in this is what it can look like. In the end, this
is just a motivation. Whatever I show you, you
don't need to understand to get I'm going to show
you maybe some key bindings, I'm going to show you
some plugins, you don't need to understand them,
I'm just showing you what you can do here. So
first of all, you can see a different theme,
you can see a different airline on the bottom
here. So status bar, you could say I can open
up a file tree on the left here, I can navigate
through directories here, I can go back here and
I can open up the tag bar, which is essentially
showing me the functions, I can use my mouse to
jump to certain functions. And since this is C, I
think I'm also able to open up the manpages here,
not sure if that works or how that works.
There you go, you have the manpages up here.
So this actually doesn't look like a terminal
editor anymore. DISA looks like VS code in a
different style. And the difference here is,
of course, also that this is not, this is not
one editor to to download, and it always looks
like that. And you can change the theme. This
is my custom editor, I decided that I want to
have a tab bar, I decided that I want to have
this file tree here, I decided that I want to be
able to open up terminals by typing terminal split
bash, I decided that I want to be able to do that.
There you go. And I can also decide to uninstall
these plugins and I can decide how I want to
have my editor. It's completely customizable.
And I do all of that. So that's the editor itself.
That's the customization. What I can do now is I
can use so called vim bindings, which we're going
to learn about to do things more efficiently. For
example, let's say I want to delete everything
that's in between this, this curly bracket
here and this curly bracket. How I would do it in
ordinary text editors. I would go select that and
delete this. What I can do here in VIM is I can
let's say I'm here, for example, at this point,
what I can do is I can just say delete inner, and
then we're actually in this case, we need to do it
here, delete inner curly brackets, and then it
does that. Again, you don't need to understand
the key bindings yet. We're going to learn about
them. I just show you what I can do here. Well,
let's say I'm here I don't I want to delete
for example the next three words so static int
get in Next, I want to delete them, I can just
type D, three W, there you go. I can undo here,
I can do all sorts of things, I can just
cut and paste using using the keyboard
without using the mouse in any complicated
ways here, I can also do something like
I'm here, I want to change everything inside
of the parentheses, I can do it like that.
So a couple of small things that you might
think first of all, are maybe complicated or
not really relevant, because who cares if
I can delete the word by typing ci w, or
by by just selecting it with a mouse, but the
fact is that I personally can say for my for
my experience that I have enjoyed a huge speed up
in my coding speed. So I think that I'm at least
300% faster, because you don't have to
use the mouse most of the time. And even
when using the keyboard, you can do things so
efficiently. And right now you might think,
okay, but typing certain characters to change. For
example, text inside of parentheses, isn't this
kind of confusing. And it isn't in the beginning
in the first place. It's confusing, but then as as
you train using vim minutes, you use it on a daily
basis, at least the key bindings, you get used
to it, and then all of a sudden, things get quite
quickly. So for example, I want to change the loop
here. I'm working right now, I don't even think
about it. I just typed CI parentheses, of course,
not in the insert mode, ci parentheses, and there
you go, I changed this. Or, I don't know I want
to change the line here. CC, I changed the whole
line. I typed something else, whatever it is. So
using Vim, first of all allows you to create your
own Neo vim setup if you want to stick with Vim,
but you can also use Vim, not only in Vim. Vim
bindings are supported by a lot of different
tools. So you can use Vim bindings via plugins
in the JetBrains IDE, so you can use it in
or use Vim bindings in VS code. You can use them
in Jupyter Notebooks, you can use them in Overleaf
in our studio in all sorts of applications. You
can use Vim bindings, they're supported, you don't
have to stick to the terminal. If you don't like
using Terminal editors, you can go with PI charm,
IntelliJ, whatever you want to use, and you can
use Vim bindings, and I guarantee you, if you
train them, they're going to speed up your coding
speed, or they're going to increase your coding
speed. So this is my motivation for now. And
now we're going to talk about the installation.
Now when it comes to the installation, it all
depends on what kind of operating system you're
working on. If you're working on Linux or Mac,
you probably have them installed already. Or
at least you have the eye. The differences
in vim means vi improved. So it's a more
recent version, a more improved version, and
you can see if you have it by just typing VI.
And if you see here, vim vi improved, you have
them installed and also bound to VI. Otherwise,
you can try to type Vim, and maybe then it says
Vim, and then you know we have it installed,
if it only has VI and it doesn't show you that
it's vi improved. So Vim, what you want to do on
Linux and Mac is you want to use your package
installer to install Vim, so on Debian based
distributions, for example, sudo, apt install,
and then Vim, or on Arch based distributions,
Pac, man, s, Vim, and so on, and so forth,
depending on your operating system, and then
you have it in your terminal. Now on Windows,
things are a little bit different. So you can
go to the PowerShell. For example, you can
install it via the PowerShell and inside of the
PowerShell. So then you have an actual terminal
editor, Vim, you can install it via G Vim, so
just download the graphical user interface to
Vim, or my preferred way of doing it is using
the Windows subsystem for Linux. So actually
running Linux inside of Windows, not with a
virtual box, but with a Windows subsystem
for Linux, which is provided by Microsoft.
So you just go to the store, you download it,
you install it, you can watch a tutorial on
that I'm not going to make one here because
this is about Vim. But you basically install
the Windows subsystem for Linux, and then you
follow the Linux steps. So just sudo apt install.
And then Vim. So this is how you install it.
That's it for the installation part. Now we're
going to start with the basics. Alright, so let
us start working with Vim, the first thing we
want to do is we want to open a file. And for that
we just type VI or vim depending on your aliases,
and then a file name, for example, clients dot c,
which is the file from before. Now in this case,
VIM is going to open the file for editing, we
can change some stuff, we can save it, we can
dismiss changes, and so on. If we type some
file name or some file path that does not exist,
what's going to happen is that we're going to
create a new file. So if I type not client C,
but something like test dot txt, this is going
to create a new file, this is going to open a
blank file, and once I write the changes to the
file, this file is going to be created by Vim. So
let us start now with client dot c, and the first
question that most people have when they enter VIM
is how do I get out of it? So I'm going
to tell you that right away, all you need
to do is you need to type colon, Q, and then
enter. Now the problem is that most people try
a lot of things before actually being able to
to get some help. or someone who tells them
how to leave Vim, so they open up a new file
test dot txt, and they just press 1000 keys,
they don't know what to do, and all
that. And then someone tells them, okay,
press colon Q, and then you're going to leave
Vim. However, this is not going to work here,
because if I press colon, Q, enter, you can
see that it says no rights since last change
at exclamation mark to overwrite. So essentially,
all you need to do in this case is you need to say
Q and then exclamation mark. And this is because
you want to say, with this exclamation mark,
you're saying quit, but also dismiss any
changes that I make. So if you make any changes,
you cannot just quit them, it's not going to
allow that you have to say, Okay, I ignore all the
changes. Just forget about those. There you go.
The important thing is here, that you don't type
exclamation mark Q, but Q exclamation mark.
And reason for that is that when you type
exclamation mark, and then something this is
a terminal command. So for example, I can say,
I don't know what can I do ls, for example,
this is going to give me the ls command
from the terminal. And if I type exclamation mark
Q, this is not going to quit. This is just going
to execute a command that is not known because
Q is not a command. So if you want to leave you
just type Q and then exclamation mark, if you want
to dismiss the changes. What if you don't want to
dismiss the changes? Let's say I want to open
a test dot txt, and I want to write something.
First of all, how do I write something because
by default, if I press for example, the key D,
we don't write ds, and also C, we don't write C's.
Okay, now we write C's. But if I press C once we
don't write C's. So why is that? And how can we
start typing some text. In order to understand
this, you need to understand that vim works with
so called modes. So when we open a new file, we
are in the normal mode, or when when we enter Vim,
we are in the normal mode. And in the normal mode,
every key has its functionality. For example, the
colon key starts a command. So if I want to type a
command, like quit, for example, or write or doing
something, or setting something, I need to type
colon and then whatever I want to execute, and
then I press enter to execute that vim command.
So the colon, the colon is actually what I press
in order to execute a command in the normal mode,
because if you're in a different mode, keys have
different functionalities. But in a normal mode,
if you type colon in something, you execute a
command, once you press enter, and other key,
like D, for example, is for deleting or A is for
appending, and so on, and so forth. We're going
to talk about those. But the first thing you
need to know is that I enters the insert mode,
if you press the letter i or the character I, what
happens is you get into insert mode, you can see
here down on the right I pressed I am now in the
insert mode, which you can see here on the bottom
left. Insert mode means that whatever I press now
doesn't have a functionality, but it's just text.
So I can write stuff here. I can also press I
don't get into another insert mode, I can press
colon, I don't get into command mode, insert
mode means that I can type text. Now if I want
to leave the insert mode again into the normal
mode, I press escape. So by pressing Escape,
we leave the insert mode, and we get into
normal mode. And now again, if I type colon,
I have a command. And if I type I enter the
insert mode escape, get out of it again,
and so on. And now we have some text, let's say
I want to save this. First of all, if I'm in the
insert mode, I need to get out of it by pressing
Escape. And then I can say colon W, which is four,
right. So if I want to write changes into
a file, I press W and I can press enter,
like that. And you can see that these
characters were written into the file.
However, I can also do right and quit. So for
example, let's say I change something here.
And I want to say quit and it says no, right
since last change, I can override it with the
exclamation mark again, I can also do wq so
write and quit. And this case it writes the
changes into the file, it also quits so I can go
ahead now and open the file again. And you can see
that all the changes are still in the file. So
this is how you can do basic stuff in vim this
is how you get into the insert mode and this
is how you get out of the insert mode into the
normal mode. Now, each character as I already said
has different functionality or has a different
functionality. So the insert mode basically means
or I basically means I enter the insert mode,
but there are multiple keys that entered the
insert mode for example another one would be eight
eight also insert enters the insert mode or oh oh
can also enter the insert mode. The difference is
how they entered the insert mode for
example, let's say I have here 123456789
And I'm focusing on a five here my cursor is above
the five and I press I would you can see is that
I if I type a now the eight is placed between
Forehand five. So when I press, I go before the
cursor before the actual focused number, if I'm
focusing to five, and now I press a instead of I,
I focus on a six. So if I type an A now, you
can see that the A ends up between five and six.
And if I type, oh, I open a new line below that
line, and then I enter the insert mode. So for
example, I'm up here, and I press O, this creates
a new line, and I'm in insert mode. And I don't
have to be at the end of the line. So it's not
like saying enter. Because when you say enter,
you just go to the end of the line, whatever.
Press enter, you also open a new line.
It's not the case here, what's the case, here's
the wherever I am in the line. So even here,
I press O, it opens a new line,
and I'm in the insert mode.
So we have i for inserting before the cursor a
for inserting after the cursor, so appending,
an O for opening a new line or for creating a new
line below the line. Now, these three characters
can also be used with the shift key in order to
have a capital letter. So capital I capital A and
capital O. And the functionality here is a little
bit different. So for example, if I'm focusing
to five, and I type shift I or a press Shift I,
this enters the insert mode at the beginning of
at the beginning of this light, so the A
is here, no matter where I am. So even if
I have multiple words here with spaces and all
that, if I'm somewhere in the middle here and I
press capital I, what you see is I jumped to the
beginning of the line, and then I typed here, the
opposite happens with capital a capital A goes to
the end of the line pens to the end of the line,
and enters D insert mode. And capital O doesn't
open a line below the current line, but above like
that. So if I'm here at this line, and I press
capital O, it opens the line above and enters
the insert mode. So those are the very basic
changes how you can change from the normal mode
into the insert mode. And from the insert mode.
Normal mode, you always press escape, basically,
this is how you can do that. Now before we
move on to other key bindings, I want to
talk a little bit about settings here because
you can see that this is really not an attractive
editor. And it's not going to be without plugins,
it's not going to be an attractive editor. But
what can make it more attractive. So first of
all, what I like to have is some line numbers,
if you want to have some line numbers in them,
which do is your type colon set, and then blank or
whitespace number. Set number basically activates
line numbers. So if I press enter, now you can see
that we have line numbers on the left. Now, one
thing that you're going to see in vim as we go on
over time, is that line numbers are actually not
line numbers. But numbers can be used to combine
key bindings, a very basic example we're going
to talk about more examples. A very basic example
is that each action can be repeated x times. So
for example, if I press the key down so that the
arrow key down, I move one line down. But if I
type five, and then arrow key down, I move five
lines down, I can do the same thing with up. So
seven up goes seven lines up. And in this line,
I can do it with left and right. So let's say
I'm here, I can say 15, right, and a jumps 15
characters to the right. By the way, one thing
that I want to mention here as well is that and
this is something where I'm not actually doing the
usual thing that you do as a vim user, especially
as a hardcore vim user. This is the part where
I'm probably too soft. I'm using the arrow keys,
just because I don't type with 10 fingers yet. But
what you can do in VIM is you can use the h, j,
k and l key instead of the arrow
key. So k goes up, J goes down,
H goes left and L goes right. So essentially,
the idea behind that is not some arbitrary keys,
those are four keys in a line. And essentially,
the reason for using those keys instead of using
the arrow keys is that you don't have
to leave the main keyboard space. So
VIM is all about optimizing your typing speed
your coding speed. So you want to type as fast as
possible, you want to use 10 fingers up optimally,
I'm not doing it but you want to use 10 fingers.
And you want to leave this space as Selim least
possible, you don't want to go to the mouse,
you don't want to go to the arrow keys, you want
to stay there. And this means that you're going
to have to use J, K, L and H in order to move
around instead of the arrow keys. But again,
I'm not doing that usually. So you can do that
better. But again, these numbers can be combined
also with the J and K. So if I go if I type
K It goes one up. If I type for K it goes for
up. So you can combine numbers with key
bindings in order to to repeat them.
Now why am I telling you that because this
happens quite often and a setting there is
certain settings that you can use in order
to make this easier. With some key bindings
in this setting is called relative number. And
not everyone is going to like it, I'm probably
I'm pretty sure that most of you who don't use
Vim or haven't used them yet, you're not going to
like the setting, but it is quite useful in this
setting is set relative number. And essentially,
instead of getting the absolute line numbers, you
get the relative line numbers to the current line.
So for the current line, you see that you have the
line number for so you get the actual line number.
But for the other lines, you get the
relative line numbers. So you can see this
line number here or this line here, it's
five lines away. So if I type five, down,
I jump to that line. And this can be quite useful
because this can be combined with deletion, this
can be combined with with pasting, with copying,
and so on. And we're going to talk about this
as we go on here. But this is just something that
you can activate if you want to you don't have to.
But you can use the Set relative number setting
here. Or you can just use the set number setting
without the set relative number setting. And
we can do a couple of different things. So
by default, for example, I cannot use the mouse
here, if I want to use the mouse, I have to set
the mouse to active so set mouse equals a. And
then I can press around here I can also scroll.
Other things would be for example, setting the tab
stop to four, setting the shift with to four and
so on or choosing a color scheme. So color schemes
late for example, you can just type color scheme
and then tap to see the different color schemes
that we have here. And then you can pick one,
enter, and you can change the color scheme.
Now, before I show you too many commands here,
what happens when I close this year, what's right
and close. What happens is I open them up again.
And all the settings are gone. So you can type
whatever you want, you don't have the settings.
So if I type set number, and I leave and I open
it up again, I don't have the numbers anymore.
And of course, if you have like 20 settings, you
don't want to set them all the time every time you
open them. So you want to have a settings file a
configuration file that does it for you. And for
that you have the VIM rc file, which is located
at the following place you go to, or actually I'm
not going to see D there. I'm going to I'm going
to vim there, so I'm going to go with vim there,
which is the user directory and then slash dot
vim RC. Now, this is the file, this is the path.
So vim recognizes that path User Directory slash
dot vim RC. If the file is there, vim loads it,
or VIM is going to open it. If it's not there, you
created in VIM is still going to load it. So we're
going to open up the VIM rc file, in this case,
we don't have it, it's a new file, we're going
to enter the insert mode. And I'm just going to
right here a couple of settings, Set number, set,
relative number, set, tap stop equal to
four cent shift with equal to four set auto
in dents. Um, I think most of them, except for
the for the first two are self explanatory,
then set mouse equal to a and color scheme, slate,
for example. So colon, W, colon, wq, whatever.
And then I can open up now again, the VIM
dots or the test dot txt file. And you can
see that I have the settings loaded, I have the
relative line numbers, I have the line numbers,
I have the color scheme. And I have also the shift
with and the tabs tab, which we cannot see here.
But this is how you do it. You can create this vim
rc file or change this vim rc file every time you
want to change and change something. For example,
if I say I don't want to use this anymore,
I want to use something else. I can delete the
color scheme and go with what do we have here
was Delic? Was that a color scheme? I'm not
sure. Yeah, or No, actually not color scheme.
Delock, it was a color scheme. Okay. Whatever, you
can change this conflict file however you want.
I like to use slate from the default themes. Later
on, we can install some with plugins. But those
are the very basics, opening files, closing files,
writing to files, entering into the insert mode,
leaving the insert mode back into the normal
mode, and then also having some basic settings
moving around. And those are the very, very basics
of them. Alright, so what we're going to do now is
we're going to look at a lot of vim key bindings
and vim key functions. And this can be quite a
lot of information to digest for a beginner.
And it might be frustrating and confusing,
because you're not going to remember everything at
once. I'm going to show a lot here. You don't have
to remember everything at once. What I recommend
you do is you watch the whole video and then once
you start training them, you go to Google and you
type vim cheat sheets, or BIM cheat sheet and then
you look for a cheat sheet that has a couple of
the things that you want to train for example,
I think this one is quite good here. from Phoenix
and AP, we're not affiliated. And essentially,
you can see here moving, inserting, editing,
copying, cutting, pasting, marking, and so on.
You have the basic commands two basic key
bindings here and you can train them you don't
have to remember them here from the video, this
video was for an overview you can play around,
you can learn the things, but you don't have
to remember everything by watching this video.
So we're going to start out with the key
bindings here, let's open a file again,
not in Vim, we're going to use the eye test dot
txt again. And now we have the text that we have
here. First of all, let me show you some basic
keys like undoing and redoing, let's say you write
something, we're going to use o to open a new
line here in the insert mode. And I type hello,
world, for example, I use Escape to go back to
normal mode. If I want to undo this right now,
what I have to do is I cannot do Ctrl Z because
Ctrl Z in the terminal gets you out of out of
the process. So it puts it into the background. So
you don't want to do that you want to type you so
just pressing the key you in normal mode uninduced
that. So you can see down here it says okay, this
happened 23 seconds ago, we have two fewer lines
now. And this basically undid the action. Now if I
want to repeat the action, so if I want to redo
the action, what I do is I press Ctrl R Ctrl R
reduce, and you undo, so Ctrl R redo. Now let's
add a couple of things here, a low then maybe what
then inserting again here is going to
normal again, up question mark going
into normal again. Now I can press u u, u u
u, or Ctrl R R or Ctrl R Ctrl R Ctrl R Ctrl R.
And what I can also do is remember we can combine
numbers and commands I can also say three you to
go three, undo back or three reduce. You can see
again here what I'm typing. Or I can say five you
for five undo. And of course, if there are no
undo to do any more, you can see already at all
this change. And I can do Ctrl R already newest
change. So this is basic undoing and redoing.
Now what's also interesting is, this is now not
related to undoing and redoing is this is a third
mode we introduced here because this can be quite
useful. We know now that we have an insert mode,
and we also know that we have a normal mode.
So insert again, we entered with either a or
O. And we can leave that with escape. But there's
also a third mode called the visual mode in the
visual mode is for selecting. Now let's say for
example, I'm here now and I want to select this
this second word here, even though it's
not a word, what I can do is I can press
V for visual mode, you can see down here it says
visual. And now if I go right, I select the word.
And now I can do certain things with that word, I
can delete it, I can copy it, I can cut it, I can,
I can do a couple of things with that word. So
now I have selected it. If I want to delete it,
what I do is I press d, d is the deletion key. So
if I press D, it deletes something, I can undo it
again now with you. And I can also of course, if
I'm in the visual mode, I can just press escape,
in this case twice, to to leave the visual
mode. So again, selecting this D deletes it.
And I can also select just a couple
of characters use D deletes dopes.
Now if I want to copy, so I can also take
that and press Y, Y is the key that we use
for yanking this is what it's called in
Vim. And yanking means copies of a press
why it says or doesn't say anything, but
it copied them. And now I can go down here,
for example, I can press P, and it enters or it
inserts it pastes basically what I yank before
and I can do that a couple of times, I can press
P, P, P, P, P, or I can also press of course
1010 P, there you go. And I can undo all that
again. So every command almost every command,
every key can be combined with a number and
then it's going to be repeated. So again,
let's select this here with visual mode, live for
yanking and then for P for pasting it four times.
And then again, I can also select all of this
year and just press D in order to remove it.
Now, these commands here or DS key bindings can
be used in different ways. So y is for yanking
D is for deleting and P is for pasting. And I
can use them in different ways. So for example,
I can select something and I
can say D as we did before,
or I can just press D D to delete the whole line.
So undo again, DD deletes the whole line dd,
dd dd. And of course again, if I go up here, for
example, and I say five DD, it deletes five lines.
There you go. same can be done with copying in
this case doesn't make a lot of sense to to copy
multiple times, but I can copy full line. So not
just selecting and copying, I can yank a full line
by going, why why and why why yanks to
full line, I can go down here and say
p. And then I can say also five p and it
adds these five lines with line breaks,
because I yank the whole line. So also the line
break. That is that, what else do we have, I can
use paste in the uppercase way. So I can also this
is the same as Oh, uppercase O and lowercase o,
if I copy, let's say this line here, and I now say
P, it's pasted below the one if I say uppercase p,
it goes above that. And of course also, if
I if I copy just a word without, without
these newline characters, I can press P to paste
at the end of the setup at the end of the of the
cursor and I can paste I can press capital P to go
before that. So same thing as I in a essentially.
So that is that now sometimes would want to do
is we don't want to delete a line, we want to
change a line. So the difference between deleting
and changing is not too much. It's essentially
the same thing. But the difference is that we
entered the insert mode when we change. So if
I just want to delete this line, I press DD and
the line is gone. If I want to delete the line,
but also change it, so I want to change what
the line is I press C C. And this changes the
line so you can see the lines not vanished. I'm
in insert mode. And I can type some stuff here.
So CC enters the insert mode, and doesn't delete
the line. Whereas DD deletes default line here.
And C can also be used in the visual mode.
So I can select for example, here the world.
And I can press C. And you can see I'm still in
insert mode, and I can type. Whereas if I select
this and I type D, I leave the visual mode,
I'm in normal mode and not in insert mode.
So those are the differences. And we can also
use the uppercase characters so I can type.
For example, if I'm here now and I press uppercase
D, this deletes the rest of the line, not the full
line if you want to delete the full line again,
dd, if you want to delete just a part of the line,
namely the last part from this cursor up until the
end, capital D deletes the rest of the line. And
capital C changes the rest of the line. That is
that, but I think uppercase Y as far as I know,
copies the full line. Yeah, uppercase Y doesn't
copy the rest of the line, but the full line. So
uppercase Y is essentially the same as why
why that is Dan dat and last but not least
when it comes or last, last but not least for the
deletion. And replacing is actually the replacing
character, which is r. So let's say I'm here with
hello and I want to change the H what I can do is
I can just press R and R means replace. And if I
now press K, you can see that it says Kelo instead
of Hello. Now what's what's what's the purpose of
that the purpose is just that I can use the R key
and I don't have to delete and then enter a new
character because an ordinary editor's would you
do is you go into the insert mode, or you don't
go into the insert insert mode, you already have
the insert mode, you delete one character and
you replace it. So I delete the H and I press
the key to enter it in Vim, I can just press R and
then H to change the key to an H. So that's that.
Now all these things like deleting, changing,
copying, and so on can be used more efficiently if
we have some keys, or some key functions that
allow us to move in an advanced way. And this
is what we're going to introduce next. Let's say
we have a simple sentence here. Low I am a simple
sentence period. What I can do now is of course I
can use the arrow keys or H J K L to move around
here. But what I can also do is I can jump words
for example. So this is this is something I can do
in in vim I can jump words forwards and backwards.
So if I'm here, I can just press W to jump to the
next word, I can press W again to jump to the next
word, and so on and so forth. I press W and it
jumps to the next word. Essentially word meaning
I'm not sure what the exact definition is, but as
far as I know word means either a space or some
special character in between. So I think if you
have something like Hello, I am a simple sentence
even though we don't have a blank here does should
I think no in this case it doesn't consider
that as multiple words but I think if we have
now I'm using by the way the are to change
the individual characters here. I think that
if I use hyphens as hyphens as you can see,
those are considered to be individual words.
However, if I go into use uppercase w, this
is one word. So if I have something here.
Uppercase W says this is one word. And those are
individual words. So the basic difference is that
if you use uppercase w you jump, or a word is
considered to be something that is separated by
by spaces. So if there's no space, it's considered
to be one word, whereas the lowercase w considers
also stuff like hyphens to be separators for
words. Now, the same thing can be done backwards.
So if I'm here, and I want to go back a word, I
basically just type B. So BBB, or if I want to
consider this a full word, I can type uppercase
B, so uppercase B, there you go. This is one
word. So the same thing that W does forwards,
B does backwards. Now why is this useful? This
is useful because we can use it together with the
things that we'll learn about already. And this is
where with vim gets very, very interesting.
Now, for example, the D key is the deletion key,
and what exactly I delete can be specified.
So for example, again, if I marked something
individual mode, this is what I'm deleting. If I
press d, d, I'm deleting the whole line. But what
I can also do is I can say d w delete a word, DW
deletes a word. And of course, I can say to d w,
delete two words. Or in this in this case, it was
basically two times delete a word I can also say
D to w, for delete two words. Essentially, this
means that where am I when I say two w, it jumps
there, everything up until this point is deleted.
So D, two w delete two words. Or also, if I'm
at this point here, I can say delete to be to go
towards backwards and delete the respective words.
However, you will notice that if I'm in the middle
of a word, and I say dw, it won't delete the full
word, but just the remaining part of the word.
If I want to delete the full word, I have to
type delete in a word, so de IW, delete in a word.
And same goes for change. So for example, if I'm
somewhere here, and I want to say, Okay, I
want to change this here to something else,
the rest is okay, I just type ci w change in
a word, and I can type something instead. Now,
you may, you may see now that this is not really
useful, because who needs that and all all that.
But this is actually quite useful. I use it on an
everyday basis, when I use JetBrains environment,
when I use VS code, when I use Neo vim doesn't
really matter. I constantly use these key bindings
because they really speed up your code,
or they really increase your coding speed.
So remember, you can specify the movements using w
and b, or also, one thing that I didn't introduce
yet yet is he, he jumps to the end of a word. So
if I type E, it jumps to the end of a word. And
also, we have the same thing for the line. So
if I want to jump to the beginning of the line,
as a movement, not as inserting, so remember,
with capital, I can go to the beginning of a line
into the insert mode. But if I just want to jump
there to specify, for example, for delete command,
I press 00 goes to the beginning of a line, and
the dollar symbol goes to the end of the line.
Again, all this you don't have to remember it
right now. Just hear about this, and then you
can look it up in a cheat sheet again. But what's
the interesting part here is that if I'm here,
for example, on type D zero, everything
up until or everything to the beginning,
or everything until the beginning, is
being deleted from the current point.
And same thing goes if I'm here, for example, and
I say D dollar D dollar basically means delete
until the end of the line. And I can do the same
thing with the end of the word. So I can see D
E, which is actually the same thing as saying DW
in this case. But this is what we can do here.
And with with a capital E, we can do the same
thing with words only considered to be words, if
they have spaces around them. We're actually not
accepting any other separators except for spaces.
So again, a lot of information to digest your so
I'm going to repeat it, you can jump around with
w you can jump around with B and you can combine
these jumps, you can also jump around with E.
You can combine all of these jumps with deletion
with copying, and with changing and all sorts of
things. So for example, let's say I want to copy
this word here, and I'm in the middle of the word,
what I do is I say why I w Yank enter word.
And then I can go down here for example,
P and I now have the word copied here. Again,
this is very useful because oftentimes,
you are coding right now you don't want to
leave the keyboard and you're here now and
you want to change this okay, just CIW There you
go. I don't have to do the D. Okay, let's select
all this here and let's press delete the delete
key here and Let's type something else I can just
while I'm in the middle of the word,
I can just type something like,
I don't have to jump to the word, I can just type
ci w and I change it right. Now, where this gets
really interesting is when we go into parentheses
and brackets and other symbols. So for example,
you might have some Python function print,
hello, world, this is my stupid message.
And since the message is stupid, you want to
delete it, you want to change it, and you're
inside of these parentheses. Now, what you usually
do is, first of all, you go to the beginning,
then you use the, the shift key and the arrow
keys to mark all of that, or maybe you use
the mouse to select all of this year, and
then you're deleted, which you can do here
with VIM is you can just go somewhere in
into the middle, and you type C i and then
quotation marks, change inner quotation
marks, and you can type something else,
right? Change, enter quotation marks. So if
you don't want to change it, you can also say,
delete inner quotation marks without entering
the insert mode. Or you can also say, yank inner
quotations, and then you can paste it somewhere.
Right. So this is just very convenient. And you
can do the same thing with, with parentheses
with square brackets with curly brackets. So
for example, if I want to, if I want to change
everything here inside of the parentheses,
I just type C, I change inner parentheses, and
I can use the opening or closing parentheses
or bracket, it doesn't really matter. So
again, hello world, then maybe we have
multiple parameters, ABC, 123, whatever,
I want to change all this here, just see i
and then opening bracket. So this can be very,
very useful. And I use this quite often. What
else do we have here? Now we can combine all of
this again, with numbers, I think I mentioned
this already. But everything that I show you
here can be combined with numbers. So I delete
five words. And I can also five times delete five
fourths, you can do whatever you want, actually.
And you can also copy five lines. So you
can say five, why, why, then P and you have
copied five lines, and so on. All this can
be combined with numbers. Now let's look at
a couple of different things. And for this,
maybe let's go to the to the client C file.
Here, we can see how this is useful. I showed it
already in the motivation. Now let's say I want
to change the function signature here. I'm not,
I'm not going to do anything meaningful here.
But let's say I want to change the parameters
here. See I parentheses, there you go. Now also,
there's another operator that we haven't talked
about yet, or another key that we can press your,
if I'm at this, if I'm focusing on this curly
bracket here, so here, and I want to know,
Okay, where is the closing one, first of all, it's
displayed here, you can see that it's highlighted.
But also I can jump to it by using the percentage
sign. So I can type percent to jump to that place.
And of course, if I have a huge functions, like
I should have one down here, here, this is the
opening bracket. And if I type percent, I go
to the closing bracket. And if I type it again,
I jumped up again. So this is very, very useful
for jumping. And of course, guess what happens
when I type D percent? It deletes everything,
including the brackets that we have down there.
Yeah, so another jump that we can do is we can
jump not a word or not to a certain certain
bracket that is closing, but to a certain
character. So for example, you might say,
Okay, I'm here. And I want to delete everything
until the next star symbol comes. So I just type,
or actually, before we start deleting, let's jump
to the next star symbol. How do I do that I say T
star, T star gets me to the position before the
symbol that I specified. So if I'm somewhere here
in the same line by in same line, by the way, so
if I say T star, I jumped one position before the
star, if I say f star, this is find it jumps to
that position. So that's a difference. Why is that
important? Because let's say I want to delete this
switch here. Now in this case, it's just a word.
Let's say we have a couple of more things. I have
some nonsense here, whatever. And I want to delete
everything up until the opening bracket, what I
can do is I can say D, T, and opening bracket,
and then it deletes everything up until this
point, if I do the same thing with F, it's a
problem because then it's going to also delete
the bracket. So I can say, d f, opening bracket,
and then we don't have the bracket anymore. So
maybe that's not what to do. But T and F are for
finding or jumping one position before that so
T jumps one position before the specified symbol
before the next current occurrence in the same
line of the specified symbol and F jumps on to
that. That's the difference here. Now I think
what capital T does, what does capital T do?
Our capital T goes backwards. So capital T and
capital F do the same thing, just backwards. So T,
or lowercase t and start jumps to the next star
and uppercase T and star jumps before to the, or
after the previous star, you can say. So you can
see one position after that. And if I type capital
F star, it jumps to the star that comes before the
current cursor. That's that. And again, this can
be combined with with deleting with yanking, I can
also say for example, I want to copy everything
up until the opening curly bracket that goes so I
basically typed in this case, oh, by the way, you
see here, I just noticed that you see here, Ctrl,
Alt, D seven, this is just because on my keyboard,
I'm using a German layout. This was just a curly
bracket. So if I type switch, if I if I type, yank
T and then curly bracket, and I paid and I press
P now this copied exactly what I want it to copy.
So this is how we can use that. And one last thing
for this section here that I want to show you is
how to jump to the beginning of a file to the end
of a file into a certain line number. So we're
somewhere here right now 291. If I want to jump to
the beginning of the file, I type GG, so lowercase
GG, like good game. And if I want to jump to the
end of the line, or to the end of the font, I type
shift G and it goes to the end. And if I want to
jump to a specific line, I can type that line. So
for example, 123 and uppercase G, then I jump
to that, or I can use a command. So I can type
colon 406, enter and a jumps a bad line. So I
would say that what we have covered up until
now are the basics of vim sort of fundamental
key bindings to fundamental commands, and so on.
And now we're going to move to some more
intermediate stuff. Now once you start
actually practicing Vim, so actually using
them on a daily basis to practice it,
I would recommend focusing on fundamentals
first and then moving on to the intermediate
stuff. But for this video, you can keep watching
to get an overview. But once you start training,
focus on the fundamentals first. So for the
intermediate stuff, we're going to cover a
quite diverse set of things. So we're going to
talk about some indentation formatting stuff,
we're going to talk about searching,
we're going to talk about replacing,
and I want to start here with the indentation.
So with the shifting offline. So for example,
let's say I'm in this line here, line, line
number 400, I want to shift it to the right,
or I want to indent it to the right. Now before
I show you the command, I want to mention that
the program here on the bottom right doesn't
translate these keys correctly. So I hope that
this is not too confusing. Essentially, what I'm
pressing here is in order to shift a line that I'm
currently at to the right, I use two times the
closing bracket. Now this translates properly,
but the opening bracket doesn't translate
properly. So this is the opening bracket for me.
So look here, not here to the bottom right.
And if I use this year, so the first line,
this indents to the right, as you can see, and
this year indents to the left. So if I do this
all the time, it indents to the left. And these
things now, so you have to press twice, if you're
just add the line, if you have selected the line,
you can just press it once. So if I use the visual
mode to select this here, I think I just have
to press once, and then it's going to indent it,
and I can select it again and I press once
back to put it to the left. Now, at this point,
I also want to mention that there are multiple
visual modes. Now up until now we have only used
just the normal visual mode, just pressing
V and selecting some some area here. We can
also use the visual line mode into visual block
mode, the visual line mode, I think it's quite
self self explanatory, we press Shift V, and we
select line so we can not select parts of lines,
we select Full lines like that. And then we can
just press Y and then press P and paste that part
and all that. But essentially, that that is
the visual line mode. The visual block mode
is something that I have to admit don't use too
often. But it can be quite useful if you need it.
It's essentially the same thing as align mode,
but column y so I can press Ctrl V to go into the
in this case, I think okay, this doesn't work
in this case because I have overwritten it.
Alright, so the problem was with
the Windows terminal, not with Vim,
so I open up another terminal here and I'm
going to open another file here. When you are
in a file in normal mode, and you press ctrl
v you enter the visual block mode and you can
select column whites like that and then you can
press D to delete the columns and so on. This
is not what you do in a visual mode and this
is not what you do in the visual line mode.
This is what you do in the visual block mode
which is controlled All v. And then you select
all these lines here. As you can see, now we can
change them. And we can, we can delete them. And
yeah, in this case, we changed them. So we
entered also cat, all these lines something,
right? So back in the previous editor, we can not
only shift lines manually by shifting them left
and right, we can also automatically indent.
And this works better with languages like C
or Java that have brackets around their code. It
doesn't work too well with Python, because then
again, you don't know. Okay, what's the proper
indentation? Do I have to indent your or not? But
in this case, let's say we have a badly formatted
code. So let's say this is somewhere here,
which is still correct code, right? But it's,
it's just ugly. And maybe we have something here.
How can I do this year, like that.
And maybe we have something like that,
like that. Now, if I want to auto indent a line,
I just have to go to that line and type the equal
sign. So not less than not greater than
just equal twice. So if I type equal twice,
this is indented correctly, there you go. And let
me just reverse this here. This can also be done
for an area. So let me just repeat the mess
here. And I can just use the visual line mode
to select a section. And then once I have
selected the section, I just type, I just
press the equal sign, and you can see everything
is indented. And this also works with the full
file. So I can combine now a couple of things
here, let me just mess up the code a little bit.
And let's remember the line here, where all
of this starts here 406. Now in order to auto
indent to full file, what I do is I type G G to
move to the beginning of the file, then I type
equals, and then capital G to move to the end of
the file. So indent until the end of the file. And
now this was what was it 406 G, they go,
everything is indented properly here.
So this worked. This is auto indentation. Now let
us move to searching. Searching is basically like
jumping. But instead of just jumping to the next
character that you find, you jump to the next
search term and searching in VIM is done using
the slash characters. So it's done like a colon,
you will see that something pops up down in the
bottom. If you type slash, and t, you can type
for example, hello. And if I press Enter, in this
case, it doesn't find Hello, because in this code,
we don't have Hello. But maybe if I type URL,
it finds URL in this case. Now this is one URL,
if I want to jump to the next URL that it finds,
I press N. So N jumps to the next. And I can
do this a couple of times, I can jump through
all the URLs here. There you go, there you go,
there you go. And I can also go back. So if
I want to go to the previous I go capital and
capital and to go back up, and then just escape,
or actually doesn't really matter escape because
URL stays saved here. Now in some color schemes,
this is going to stay marked, you just type slash
again and you enter some nonsense. There are some
fancy ways to reset it. But this is basically
how everyone does it. If you want to search
backwards, so not the next occurrence. But the
previous occurrence, you use the question mark, so
question mark URL, and you basically the normal n
basically moves up now and the capital n moves
down now. So this is just the reverse of that.
What we can also do is we can select a token. How
does this work? Let me just type something else
here so that we reset it. So if I press Scan, we
don't find URL now. Now I can select URL and I can
type hashtag. Actually, this is still individual
mode. Now I have this token, I type hash tag to
find the next occurrence of that token. So hashtag
goes up in this case, again, this this doesn't
translate properly. It says that I'm pressing
question mark. So don't be confused by that. But
this hashtag basically means moving up. And
if I go with star star goes to the next one.
So star goes to the next occurrence of the token.
So here if I go to length and I press star,
it goes to the next length, length length that
you got. And hashtag goes up again. Again,
hashtag what I'm actually typing here is
this character here. Not the question mark.
So that is that what do we have else now we
can we can do something quite interesting,
which is marking locations and jumping to
those locations. So let's say for example,
I frequently re visit a function for some reason,
for example, extract hostname here, and especially
this line 130 This chord cursor here I come here
quite often, what I can do is I can mark that as
a waypoint. So I can set a waypoint by typing
M and I can now choose a character for example,
M A, which would mark this as being the Mark A.
And if I now am at a certain different position
here, and I want to jump to a certain way point,
I just press this single quotation mark here,
and then a and then jumps there. And I can
also go to a different point here, for example,
extract full status to the string copy here,
m, and I can type G, so, mg in this case,
now I go somewhere else, and I can type
single quotation, a single quotation G.
And this can be used to mark important sections in
the code to jump through them and to not have to
scroll all the time or remember line numbers, you
can just say, Okay, jump to the waypoint a there,
I have a certain piece of code, jump to waypoint
K, there, I have a certain code section and so on,
you can navigate through large code files using
these waypoints. Now, another little thing we
can do is we can center the current selection. So
if I'm down here, you can see it doesn't scroll
necessarily, just because I move my mouse here,
or move my cursor here. If I want to center the
current line, so I want to move it up into the
screen, I just typed ZZ. So two times lowercase z,
and then it's centered is and this can be quite
useful, especially if you have something like
a new found. Let's just remove all this here. And
now let's say I go down somewhere. And I don't
really have anything to scroll down to, what I
can do is I can type z z to still center that
even though there are no lines below that. So let
us move back to the C file. The last two things
that I want to show you here for the intermediate
category are searching and replacing. So basically
just substituting and repeating a command, so
substituting strings and repeating commands.
And for that, let's take some string that
occurs quite often, for example, character here,
you can see character occurs quite often. Let's
take that and replace each occurrence with another
string. How do we do that in vim with a command,
so we need to type colon, and then percent to make
it into full file, not just in the selection, not
just in the current line, but in the full file.
And then we type S for substitute slash for
character, and then slash, and let's replace
character with symbol for example, a synonym and
then slash G. And once we do that, I press Enter,
and you can see all the occurrences here have
changed across all lines in the full file.
Now let's say I want to do something similar.
But just in a selection, let's say I want to
select this area here. And let's say Do we
have a word that occurs a couple of times.
Let's just take symbol again and do it and rename
it to something else. Now, we select that and then
we type again, colon, and this time, we don't
use percent, we just use S, we don't want to
do it in the full file, we just want to do it in
a selection. So s slash symbol, slash something,
slash Jeep, there you go. Here, it changed. Here,
it didn't change. So this is how you do that.
And the last thing that I want to show you here
for the intermediate category is repeating a
command is actually quite simple. Let's say I
delete a line by typing DD. All I need to do
in order to delete another line is to press
the period or the.so. The point basically,
this executes the command that I just executed.
So this just repeats the command. But this is
not a macro. This is just the last command. So
this is just a single command, not a sequence of
commands. So also, for example, if I say, change
until or let's let's go here, for example, yeah,
let's do it here. Delete until the quotation,
I do it here. And now I can go somewhere else,
maybe we have some similar. Let's say here, for
example, I just press period, and it does the same
thing. So this is just repeating the command. So
the last thing that I want to talk about when it
comes to vim bindings, and vim commands is macros
and registers. And this is quite an interesting
topic because essentially, whenever we delete
something, or whenever we we copy something,
whenever we Yank something, you could say this is
stored into a register, and we can see the list
of registers in vim by typing the command colon
Rec. So colon rec, enter, and you can see here
the individual registers you can see the name of
the register, and you can see the content of that
specific register. Now one thing I'm not sure if I
mentioned that whenever you delete something using
D is also copied. So if I say if I if I go to a
certain line here, for example, return negative
one, and I say DD, I delete that line, but I can
also paste it again, because it is also copied.
So deleting in vim means copying at the same time.
So basically, deleting means cutting you could say
and if you want to have multiple clipboards,
in In Vim, you basically have that because
if I delete something, if I copy something, I
have the different registers that store these
things. Now I can also let's let's go ahead again
and see wreck here, I can also choose a certain
registered to paste from. So for example,
if I want to paste this here, the registers
seven returned to false status length. This is a
comment. If I want to do that, all I have to do is
not just press P in order to paste but before that
press quotation mark seven p. So take the register
quotation mark seven and paste from that, I can
do the same thing with copying, I can go to that
line and see quotation marks seven y y to yank
the line into seven. register that go seven get
hostname Link function. So this is how that works.
Oh, actually didn't want to leave that file.
And there's some special registers. For example,
the register with with a named quotation mark plus
essentially means that or essentially represents
the clipboard whenever you copy something in your
system, provided the name is integrated with your
system, of course. But when you copy something,
it is stored in a register, which is
quotation mark plus, this is a register.
So you can use that to copy into the clipboard
from vim or to paste from the clipboard in Vim.
This is something you can do. And also something
that's quite interesting is again, when you delete
something, you already have it ready for pasting.
But what for example, if I want to just copy this
line here, sort of static in I just typed y y to
yank that line, so I can paste it, as you can see,
but I also want to delete that line and still
paste what I just copied. So I want to delete
your if I just pay if I just press P, I just
press P and I and I paste what I just deleted.
If I want to paste the last thing
that I copied that I actually yanked,
I have to use the zero registers. So I
type what was it, quotation mark, zero P,
and it pastes. The last thing that I actually
yanked. Not that was copied by cutting or deleting
is important. Now, when it comes to Macros, macros
are actually also stored in registers, and we can
store them in registers manually. So a macro is
essentially just a sequence of vim bindings of vim
actions, you could say, for example, what could be
such a thing, I could go here to a certain line,
and a macro would be delete the lead three
words that go and then go to the end of the line
and add 100, for example, whatever this is, a
stupid macro doesn't have any value. But if I
want to record that macro, what I do is I press
Q, to define that I want to start recording a Q
A means record the macro, as you can see down here
recording a, and now I can do whatever I want to
do. So every action I take now is going to be part
of the macro, for example, the lead three words,
capital A to jump at the end of the line
into insert mode, and then 100 escape.
Now I want to quit the macro cue, quit
recording. Now the macro is stored in a
and I think we should also see that in the
registry here, you can see that the macro
that register a has d3, w a 100 as a macro
This is those are the keys that I just typed.
And they're now stored in the macro eight. If I
want to execute that macro, all I need to do is
I need to use the Add symbol. So the male symbol,
I hope this is translated correctly here. Okay,
it isn't in my case. But essentially, this is what
you get on American keyboards by pressing shift
in two. So essentially just this at
sign here, this is what you press. And
what you do in order to execute the macro is
you go to a line where you want to execute it,
for example, this line here and you type at A and
as you can see the leader three words and added
100 At the end of the line, again at a at a and
so on. And I think we should even be able to use
the point now. Yeah, we can
use even the period now.
No, actually not this is just repeating the
last character forget about a set just at a
at a this executes the macro and of course what
you can do here is you can also define a macro B
that does something else and then you can define
a macro C that executes macro A and B. So you
can you can combine them you can you can have a
so called you could say composite pattern where
you have one macro using five other macros that
again use five other macro. So you can make pretty
complicated things here. And this can be quite
useful. I have used it a couple of times already.
And those are I would say the basic intermediate
and advanced things that you need to know about
vim itself. Now finally, last but not least,
I want to show you how you can take the simple
primitive Vim and turn it into an actual advanced
editor. into something maybe even approximating
an IDE with a lot of plugins. And before you do
that though, keep in mind that if you're starting
out with Vim, if you're learning it for the first
time, I recommend you stick to the Manila version
for the first couple of weeks. So you just learn
the basic vim stuff, the basic vim key bindings,
the basic vim functions and settings and commands
and all that. And you don't bother using some
plugins because those themselves have different
commands and different key bindings and different
settings, and so on. So focus on the basics in
once you have the basics down, you can you can
install some plugins you can you can customize
your setup. Now, in order to do this, what we need
to do first here, or just recommended to do first
year is to install niobium instead of Vim, new VIM
is just better faster, and it supports more
plugins that vim does not support. So if you want
to have a better experience, and you still want to
keep using vim in the terminal, I recommend to use
Neo Vim, and for that we type sudo apt install
Neo vim on Linux, I have this installed already.
And in my case, if I now type Neo Vim, it opens
a NEO vim full of plugins you can see here
in a second it opens dashboard, it opens a couple
of things. Your new vim when you install, it will
look probably like the basic vim just it's going
to say Neo vim instead of Vim. So in order to
install plugins, what you need to do is you need
to go to the browser, you need to go to Google
and you need to type vim plug or you can just go
to the link here, get up at comm slash June gun
slash vim dash pluck. And then you can read the
instructions here. All you need to do once you
have nuvem installed is you copy this year on Unix
and Linux. So also on Windows, if you're using the
Windows subsystem for Linux, you're copying that,
pasting it running it, and that's it, then you
have vim plugin installed, basically. And one
thing that you need to know is that the Neo vim
config is not a vim rc file. So it's not using the
same conflict as the basic vim installation. The
Neo vim config is located in the User Directory
slash dot config. And then here, I think it was
was it new Vim? Or was it in Vim? I think it was
in them right? There you go. In here, we have a
file called or usually you don't have a file, you
need to create one called init dot Vim, so can't
in it, dump him. This is my file. This is
the content of my file here. So usually,
you don't have the end of directory and you also
don't have the init dot bin file. So you created
you create both of them, you create the directory,
and you create the init dot WIM file in this
actually want is going to be used. Now you can
see that my file here is quite comprehensive,
you don't need to understand anything that's
written here. This is my config. But the basic
structure is quite simple. So first of all, what
you see up here is the commands we already talked
about, you know, tap, stop, smart, tap, auto, and
then now we didn't talk about smart tap, whatever
number relative number all that. Then down here,
you can see a bunch of settings that you don't
need to understand the they are plugin specific.
For example, here I have a plugin called vim tax,
and has some certain parameters or settings that
I want to pass here, I have set certain icons up
here all details that don't matter to you right
now, what you need to understand is that there
is this section here, once you have been plug
installed, what you can do is you can type call,
pluck, hashtag begin, and then call plug hashtag
end. And in between. Now this is actually
not on the right place here. So ignore that.
But in between those two commands, we install
the plugins by typing pluck, and then the link
to the GitHub repository. That's literally all
we need to do in order to install or to actually
to say that we want to install them plugins,
in order to actually install them, we need
to type colon plug installed, like that
colon plug install, and then it's going to open up
on the left here, the plugin installation. In my
case, it says already installed already installed
already installed. And all these things here, all
these plugins are just get up repositories. Vim
surround is a git repository nerd tree, which is
the thing you see on the left here. This is nerd
tree, just a GitHub repository. So all you need
to do is you need to go to the repository, which
is a vim plugin. You copy the link, you type plug,
there you go. And then so you have this section
called plug begin, called plug and in between
plug in and the link, and then essentially you go
in and you say plug install, and it's installed
the plugin, then maybe you have to rerun and
then the plugins are activated. And what you
do with the individual plugins, so which color
schemes you choose what settings the plugins have,
I cannot make a tutorial on that because each
plugin is unique. So nerdery has certain things to
set up. Vim commentary has different things to set
up. But all these plugins have functionalities,
for example, with vim commentary, I can just
go to a couple of lines. I can mark them and
I can type DC to comment. them out. And this is
across multiple different programming languages.
So this is not a default vim key binding. This is
an advanced thing this that is introduced with vim
commentary, the airline's would you see down here,
so I don't want to talk too much about specific
plugins here. Those are my plugins. And I also
have on my GitHub repository, I can show you that
for those of you who are interested on my
GitHub I have so on github.com/neural, nine,
I have my conflict files for those of you who want
to have my installation, but keep in mind that
so you go to conflict fonts and go to it Vim. Keep
in mind, this is a pretty advanced setup, oh, this
is actually an outdated version. So maybe pick
this one, it's it's a little bit more lightweight.
But you're going to have to go through some
installation steps, maybe you have to install
Node, maybe you have to install a language server
and all that. But those are the plugins I use,
you can just go online type, top 10 vim plugins
to install, install those in, that's it.
And the good thing is that this is not one IDE
or one editor that you download, like VS code,
and then install some plugins. This is your thing,
this is how you designed. So with those plugins in
my settings, I have a unique setup that no one
else has, unless of course, they copy my config,
but you can have your setup the way you want it.
And this is very awesome. This is how you can set
up Neo vim to be actually something approximating
an IDE. Now using vim or new VIM is your actual
editor is fine. But oftentimes, you're going
to make use of pi trami going to use IntelliJ,
you're going to use our studio, you're going
to use a Jupyter Notebook, you're going to use
Overleaf and so on. And most tools out there,
since VIM is really an awesome tool, and a lot
of people like it support vim bindings, either
natively or through a plugin. So for example,
in pi term here, for Python development, you can
go to File to settings, and you can go to plugins,
and you can download the idea of in plugin,
you can install the idea of in plugin. And
once you have that in PI charm, you can use Vim
key bindings. Now of course, you cannot install
1000 plugins here because this is pi charm. This
is not Vim, you cannot install nerd tree and all
that. But you can use the VIM bindings, so I'm
here in PI charm. And I can say for example,
change inner parentheses, there you go. Undo with
you. I can use visual mode here, I can press C
in order to change and all that. So all these
things work here, all the basic key bindings
work also in PI charm, also in Overleaf, also in
our studio, and Jupyter Notebook, all that. And
for the intelligent products or for the JetBrains
products, so IntelliJ pi term and so on.
You also have an actual vim rc file, which is
called Idea RC. So you go to your users directory,
and then you go to idea vim RC. And they
offer actually two plugins. So they offer
surround in commentary surrounding commentary
are actually vim plugins. And you cannot use
plug install here. So you cannot use Vim plug in
pi charm, but you can use surround and commentary.
So commentaries, basically, what I told you, you
select a couple of lines, and you type GC and it
comments them out. Or you just go to a single
line, just type GCC to comment the line out.
This works also in Python by setting. Setting the
commentary and surround is basically surrounding a
word. So for example, if I picked this one here,
I think it was y SW are actually y s, inner W,
quotation marks like that. This basically
for surrounding, not too important,
but this is what I do on a regular basis.
I use Neo vim sometimes if I just edit some
some small scripts or something. But if I use
an IDE, if I use PI charm, if I use IntelliJ,
whatever I do, unless maybe Microsoft Office,
so unless unless I do some word stuff,
I always use use Vim bindings everywhere. And this
speeds up your code, so you don't have to use Vim.
Even if you don't like the terminal. Even
if you don't want to use Vim in a terminal.
I recommend starting to use Vim bindings in your
other IDE, including Visual Studio code. So that's
it for this vim course. I hope you enjoyed it and
hope you learned something. If so let us know by
hitting the like button and leave a comment in the
comment section down below. Besides that, don't
forget to subscribe to Free Code Camp and maybe
you're also interested in checking out my channel,
neural nine. I make a lot of videos on data
science, machine learning Python and so on.
So if you're interested, take a look. And
besides that, thank you for watching SEO and bye